ومتابعه لتطورات العاجله نقلا عن وسائل
اعلام تابعه لانصار الله الحوثيين غارات
امريكيه بريطانيه على العاصمه اليمنيه
صنعاء متابعه لذلك معنا من صنعاء مراسل
الجزيره محمد العطاب محمد ماذا عن هذه
الغارات الاخيره في
صنعاء نعم شن الطيران الامريكي البريطانيه
عده او سلسله من الغارات التي استهدف من
خلالها جبل عطان جنوب جنوب صنعاء وايضا
بخمس غارات استهدف بها هذا الجبل وايضا
كان هناك ايضا استهداف اخر ل لمنطقه جبل
النهدين وهو جبل يقع جنوب مجمع
للرئاسه وهو ايضا من ضمن الاهداب التي
استهدفت في الفتره السابقه وايضا استهدف
في جبل اخر يقع شرق صنعاء وهو منطقه الحفا
وهو التابع منطقه تابعه لجبل نقم وايضا
استهدف في في تعز
منطقه
الحوبان وكذلك قبل ساع ساعتين او ثلاث
ساعات استهدف مديريتي الدريهمي
ومديريه الدريهمي وايضا واللحيه في
الحديده وهي من
المناطق المطله على البحر الاحمر وهي جنوب
محافظه الحديده تستمر هذه الاستهدافات في
ظل ما
يقوله الجيش الامريكي البريطاني انه
يستهدف
قدرات جماعه انصار الله و وذلك للحد من
قدتها لاستهداف سفن السفن التابعه
لاسرائيل
وكذلك للحد من قدراتهم وايضا
تهديد القدرات العسكريه جماعه الصار الله
لق الطائرات الامريكيه وايضا للارجات
والسفن الامريكيه فيما لا يزال على الارض
الواقع لا يزال جماعه انصار الله لهم اليد
الطوله ايضا في القيام بعدد من العمليات
في البحر الاحمر خلال ما ذكره زعيم جماعه
انصار انه فقط في اسبوع ارتفعت وتيره
العمليات التابعه لجماعه الصله حيث
استهدفوا عش قاموا بعشر عمليات ف فيقول
ايضا محليون وخبراء بان العمليات التي
يقوم
بها التحالف الثنائي البريطاني الامريكي
انه ليس ليس بمقدوره ان يستهدف قدرات
الحوثيين خصوصا وانهم يعملون كما يسمى
بغوريلا وور وهي الحرب ما يسمى بحرب
العصابات حيث يتكون من اثنين الى ثلاثه
الى اربعه اشخاص يقومون بعمليات محدده
ومقتضي عودون مره اخرى في التمويه المختلف
فهذه يصعب على الجيوش المؤسسيه والعسكريه
ان تستطيع ان تقاتل مثل هذا النوع من هذه
الحروب ا